بدي اشكرك ويعطيكم الف عافيه على مجهودكم
العظيم اللي بتقدموه رغم قله الامكانيات
وبساطه الامكانيات لكن انا شاهدت في مطبخ
كمان يبدو انتوا هنا بتعملوا الاكل
وتجهزوا الاكل
تشوفوا العياده الطبيه اللي عنا هي عباره
عياده الطبيه اسرت العيال الطبيعي الدراسي
اشعناها واحضرنا الادويه من بيوتنا
والمعارفنا من مرسين
سريعا بس نطلع على العياده التي انشؤوها
هنا في هذا المركز يعني لاجراء اسعافات
اوليه للمصابين انا طبعا كنت شاهدت بعض
المصابين هنا شباب ونساء اصاباتهم طفيفه
ومنهم من يعني على سبيل المثال ساقوا
مجروحه جرح عميق هذه العياده التي
انشاتموها
تمام المقاعد
الدراسه نعم لا لحظه خلي الكاميرا توصل
نعم عملت سرير من مقاعد الدراسيه
نحن استخدامنا جميع البني التحتيه اللي
عندنا شو في عنا التحتيه استخدمناها ما
خليني اشيلها هذول المقاعد الدراسي
استخدمناها جميعا شوف يعني بطاريات من
البيوت احضرنا
الفرش طلبناه من اصدقائنا من اسطنبول ومن
مرسين ومن الريحانيه بالنسبه للادويه هاي
من وين جبتوها
هي كلها من البيوت ما في خطر مده الصلاحيه
اللي كنت يعني انتم مهتمين بهذا الامر
موجود دكتور الان هو موجود دكتور نزل داخل
السوري طلبوه اللي هو متابع الموضوع اذا
في شيء منتهي صلاحيته بيحطه على جنب بس
لكن هذا يعني نحن بنقول
خجوله ما نقول بدائيه معلش معلش يعني رغم
نقص الامكانيات وقلتها وتواضعها ولكن
مشكورين جدا على جهدكم وهذه الملابس طبعا
هذه الملابس مستخدمه في حال اه في حال
الوضع هذا اما الملابس الجديده انه نحن
احد الاخوات الموجوده اللي هي ام النور
الله يجزيه الخير
كل ولد على مقاسه اللي ما عنده لباس ممكن
ياخذ لباس جديد اما المستعمل فهو مباح
للجميع ميسون يعني هذه جوله سريعه في هذا
المركز مركز الايواء يعني الامكانيات
متواضعه جدا بسيطه جدا ولكن هذا هو الحال
وهذا هو الواقع صحيح وبتعرف عمار ابتسامه
العطاء جميل جدا يعني شعوره هو عم بيشرح
لالنا ما الذي يقدم رغم انه الامكانيات
قليله تثلج الصدر
صحيح صحيح صحيح طيب